We're so flawed in our approach.
It's really interesting that it's like
the human body and the human mind is such
an incredibly complicated
biological entity, right?
Our ability to consciously be
aware of our, our, our life,
our position in the world,
our mortality,
the insignificance of
us in the greater scale.
All those things are like
there right now all the time.
But they don't have any
users manual, right? Exactly.
Like we have this incredible machine
that can invent nuclear bombs and
satellites and there's
no union users mantle,
no user's manual for the mind or the body,
especially not in how to manage the
body with the mind. Yeah. Nothing,
nothing figured out. Bitch wide open.
If you're on your own few people of God,
you've got to like find these masters,
right?
So if you think about the 300 and
whatever million people we have in this
country,
how many of those people could guide you
towards a a proper integration of mind
and body and a positive way of interfacing
with reality that's beneficial to you
physically, mentally, spiritually,
[inaudible] is there a dozen?
Not many.
Isn't it an interesting,
very interesting.
All these human beings and essentially
most of them trying to improve in some
way. Even people that fail on diets,
boy, they'd like to get skinny.
Even people that you know fail at school.
Why I wish I was smart enough to graduate.
I wish I had enough discipline peop
people want to do better so there's this
vast need for coaching that would
lead to improvement yet almost,
I mean nothing to speak of and certainly
not nothing large scale in any city
that has this approach where look,
we're going to teach you how to better
engage with the material world around you
and the the better engage with reality
itself that's going to leave you a more
spiritually,
physically,
emotionally fulfilled like that
seems like that'd be a big business.
One way to teach this stuff is by
example that if a person exemplifies,
you know,
good mind body functioning,
they can inspire that and another person
that seems like maybe the only way,
one strategy that I, if I can
do this, if I have a patient,
if I can introduce that patient to
someone who's had their condition is now
better.
That is a very powerful way to up their
belief in the possibility of getting
better. Yeah, that makes sense. Which is
why people love user testimonials. Right.
But, but better if you actually meet
the person and show, see for yourself,
but use your testimonials are so
huge for that razor. You know,
I was skeptical at first,
but then I tried it and boy,
he was skeptical just like me.
Yeah. It's, uh, it, uh, to me,
when I look at the giant number of
people that are unhappy and displaced and
just seem like they're left out
of society, I was listening to,
oh, it was a Johann Hari
on Sam Harris' podcast.
And you were talking about the number of
people that are happy with what they do
for a living, happy with
what they do every day. And
it was somewhere around 13%.
Yeah. And then the number of people
that were just like, it's okay.
I just do it. Like I don't
hate it, but I don't love it.
That was like in the 60% and then the
rest of the people fucking hated what they
did.
So the vast majority,
some ungodly number,
you know,
like 87% of people hate what
they're doing. Oh, how sad.
Or if don't hate it, they don't want to
be doing it. And they do it all the time.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That that has to have a profound
effect on all aspects of your life.
Right.